If you got these answers excellent work. This would be the expanded form for the
first problem. We have four 2s and three 2s. So all together I would have 2 to
the 7th. I have seven 2s multiplied together. The second problem is very similar
to this first problem. Instead of having a 3 as our base, we have an x. We have
some unknown number. So we have 3 of those x's multiplied by 2 of those X's. So
all together, we have 5x's multiplied. Or X to the 5th. Here's the expanded form
for the 3rd expression. Notice that I have x's and y's. So these bases aren't
the same. And i can't combine them. I just have to list x to the 3rd and y to
the 4th. That's my answer. &gt;&gt; For the last problem, this is the expanded
expression. Since I have a product of factors, I can rearrange the factors to
group the like terms together. For example, these x's can be moved over here.
And these y's can be moved to the right. We can do this because the community
property of multiplication. We know 3 times 2 is the same as 2 times 3. If ever
I have a bunch of factors, I can rearrange the order of those factors. We'll
still wind up with the same number. Now this is a little bit easier to see. I
have x to the 7th and y to the 7th. So these are the most simplified expressions
with exponents.